so I went back I came home
and I was out like four months oh you
went back yeah I went back bro I was out
four months and then um I broke some
Fool's nose at a bar over some stupid
[ __ ] damn so I went back again for four
months and that's when really like the
humbling came you feel I'm saying like
that's from the moment of reflection
like like I told myself like damn you're
a grown ass man like you ain't got [ __ ]
to show for it oh you got a CDC numbers
you feel me like but you talk all this
gangster [ __ ] like to me gangsters ain't
broke you know yeah I also feel like
people got to start to understand like
at a certain point in time like if
someone talks [ __ ] to you at a bar yeah
like it's probably the more gangster
thing to be the bigger guy and just like
you know what now I know now I'm the
type of [ __ ] like the minute I
see [ __ ] hey you want to drink bro I got
you the [ __ ] is this man drinking you
know yeah I bring the stripper over here
give the boy a laugh he needs to cool
down you know what I'm saying because
I'm not afraid of what he's gonna do I'm
afraid of what I'm gonna do bro like
consequences yeah well I know I got
everything to lose so when you got
everything loose you Playing for Keeps
you feel I'm saying I'd rather I'd
rather just you know I mean like try to
avoid this [ __ ] dog because at this
point like there's no profit in it you
know yeah I think people got to
understand like um
you can literally change your life just
making one mistake hell yeah you could
be drinking too much one decision though
could cost you everything it could cost
you everything everything literally and
let's say you get it you might get into
a fight at a bar and then you hit
somebody and then they fall and they hit
their head look around and then you're
[ __ ] ninja over the rest of your life
picture this scenario right you go to
prison
and this happened to me that's why I'm
speaking you go to prison
and you know your Bae mom's at home with
the kid yep and you're fighting this
[ __ ] together and you're thinking
there's a bond right because you know we
tend to have that illusion we're busted
like people gonna ride it out with us or
people gonna be there for us one time I
called home
and literally the girl that I was being
with
took the phone off the hook accepted my
call and put it on speaker
so that I could hear her getting my
little girl ready to go out for dinner
with another man oof
and then think about it like I'm gonna
be honest with you I stood there and I
heard the whole [ __ ] I couldn't hang up
like no matter how much ego and how much
pride and how much gangsterism is in me
I couldn't I couldn't I couldn't hang up
bro right you know what I'm saying but
those are the vulnerable positions you
put yourself when you're taking those
losses you feel what I'm saying and also
like to be honest like it's also
probably not fair to expect someone
exactly to wait for you that's the way
that because you you want you want hell
yeah if you really love that girl let
her go you should allow her to go and
because you were facing even even if it
was 18 years right yeah it's like come
on like you kind of want to make it yeah
but it's but it that's that's what I'm
saying though it's an unrealistic
reality that we expect yeah you know
what I'm saying like our expectations
are way too pure for the filth that we
live in you know what I'm saying like we
expect [ __ ] to have honor and
not snitch we expect [ __ ] to
have honor and not run from a fight we
expect women to stay loyal even though
we were probably cheating on them
because I was cheating like a
[ __ ] when I was out right I was
cheating I wasn't coming home but
your arrogance makes yourself and you
start to believe that you're entitled to
a lot of [ __ ] that you're not right you
know what I'm saying so when you go away
that's why I found so much on people
snitching and debriefing because you
think you're doing something dog at the
time right you might think like oh you
you got the best of the system [ __ ]
everybody I'm getting out they weren't
gonna ride for me anyways now bro like
what you're missing is the lesson that
you're gonna get during that time you
were busted you know what I'm saying
like you're shorting yourself from life
experiences and virtues like only on
your own you can learn because Solitude
is the best teacher bro to find out who
you are to find out what you're prepared
for and to find out like exactly how far
you'll take something like I knew in
prison I couldn't do life I admit that
[ __ ] like I can't do life dog I love
[ __ ] I love my freedom you know what
I'm saying I like what comes with
providing I like living with a purpose
you know what I'm saying and that was
the biggest thing for me in prison was
like waking up
you're just staring at a wall dog no
opportunity no no nothing you're just a
empty shell of existence you feel I'm
saying like there's nothing bro nothing
yeah even writing letters felt stupid
after my eighth year I bet you know like
why the [ __ ] am I riding these people
let me write back don't give a [ __ ]
you're over here pouring your soul out
on a [ __ ] letter
and [ __ ] don't even open it
when it gets home and I'm in the same
place now like trust me all my homies
write me and this and that most time I
don't have time to write back or even
read them bro wow like I got to be on a
trip where it's two hours where I'm like
you know what the homie Romie let me
call his mom I'm gonna send her Zeal her
100 bucks for him and tell him I said my
love I can't write back yeah
[ __ ] call my phone all day I
don't got time to answer bro like I just
don't
know what I'm saying but that's the fact
that's the facts the world keeps turning
without you